Israel is at War and I'm asking all
Ministries all reborn Christians to
please pray with us we here stand with
Israel and the evil that is working
behind the
scenes stand no chance because God has
already overcome this world so we are
not afraid but it is our responsibility
to pray without ceasing and these things
just shows us that we are getting closer
to the end
times let's pray for
Israel there's a lot of innocent people
who are getting hurt who are
dying the devil is at
work but God is Lord of lords he is king
of kings and we should not fear he has
not given us a spirit of fear but of
power of love and selfcontrol so let's
pray